New York magazine national correspondent
Gabriel DeBenedetti joins us Gabe good
morning let's start with the bill shine
as as Michelle mentioned v White House
communications director to go out this
revolving door what's the significance
of this well it's unclear you know
immediately whether this is going to
change anything inside the White House
because of course the truth is while
there have been five what has
communications directors six people have
accepted the job there's really only
been one all along and that's Donald
Trump at the end of the day he drives
the news and this is a White House that
it's not unfair to say it thrives on
chaos so this was never really going to
be a role that made a ton of sense for
someone who was going to come in and try
and really professionalize the operation
now we'll see what kind of role Cheyne
has in the re-election campaign it's not
really been defined yet more than a
dozen Democrats have entered the 2020
race we've heard some from some
prominent Dems that they're not running
well we haven't heard or who we haven't
heard from was Joe Biden is he gonna run
a great question you and everyone else
want to know that right now including a
lot of people around Joe Biden he's been
telling his advisers he's about 90 95 99
percent of the way there but there have
been a lot of people around him who
basically say he has to cross that final
threshold he of course has gotten to
this point five times before he's run
twice not done very well he's concerned
not only about his family but about the
modern political landscape it's changed
a lot he's been around for a very long
time and at the end of the day here it's
a it's a complicated thing you know he
has changed his timeline over and over
and over I've been reporting on him for
years but for the last few weeks I've
heard he's gonna make his decision by
the end of 2018
by the end of January by the end of
February by the end of March now it
sounds like he'll probably launch a
campaign in April but probably it gave
one of the things obviously making
headlines this morning is the sentencing
for Paul manna for 47 months and that's
raised a question about the idea of
sentencing and some of the issues that
we may have in the disparities but also
with manna fort we're not done there is
more to come for him that's right he
will this this week go before a judge in
Washington this is a judge who's been a
little bit tougher on him in the past
and who could give him up to ten years
it's for a slightly different situation
this is for you no witness tampering
potentially and also for some of the
work that he did with Ukraine so it's a
different different
this was Washington the last one was
Virginia he could go behind bars for 10
more years but you're right it has
spurred a national conversation in an
interesting way about sentencing and the
possibility of sentencing reform that
said we'll see what happens this week
this coming week Gabe also that the
Senate scheduled to vote on the
president's national emergency
declaration it is the Republicans gonna
stand by the president well most of the
Republicans are but the real question
here is whether two or three or four are
not and right now there are four of them
in the Senate who say that they're not
going to stand by him and that means
that he's going to have to veto their
rebuke of him if everything that we
expect comes to pass right now again
there are four Republican senators we're
going to join Democrats if nothing
changes in essentially saying that this
national emergency declaration is know
as a no go it's not fair it's not good
it's not legal if that comes to pass the
president is going to have to veto his
own Republicans vote here well the
president and Republicans have said on
the Michael Cohen front that he's a liar
my question is as far as the Democrats
are concerned did Cohen tell enough of
the truth in other words you know did he
connect the dots with enough proof it's
a good question and we don't actually
know what he said behind closed doors
right and so that's one of the big
questions here because he does continue
to testify in confidential settings that
were not seeing on camera a lot of
Democrats have said that he's given them
a ton of information to show that the
president was complicit in essentially
the crimes that Michael Cohen is
accusing him of but the question of
credibility really is the big one right
now and there's a reason that not only
the president but basically every
Republican out there is not even trying
to go after necessarily what Cohen has
to say but just trying to prove that
he's not a trustworthy narrator here
they're just trying to say Democrats can
think he's connecting the dots they can
think that he's showing that Donald
Trump committed campaign finance
violations but he's not someone that we
can trust in the first place Democrats
are trying to prove that's not the case
but it's tough and we await the moment
report yes thank you thank you